protecting children in a pandemic is a
must
education is vital but so is preventing
violence and sexual abuse
their mental state is also at risk in
isolation
this point in time could map out the
rest of their lives
unicef warns the crisis could push up to
86 million more children into poverty by
the end of the year
it also expects a spike in child labour
what sort of future would you want for
your kid
[Music]
well this crisis has been an
inconvenience for many of us
for others it's been horrific and could
set
some children back for the rest of their
lives i'll talk to an expert about that
in a moment
first this report it's a tense evening
in nairobi's kibara district
an ambulance has brought a weak elderly
man back to the village who has
supposedly tested negative for the
coronavirus
but many here suspect that he's still
sick it's not entirely clear what his
status is
but people are worried enough to force
the ambulance to take him back to the
hospital
officially there have been around 11 000
cases in kenya so far
which is relatively low but there's
widespread fear of a major outbreak
schools have been closed because of the
coronavirus
a potentially devastating blow to the
future of the younger generation here
mothers like sophia ashi hundu can't
homeschool their children
the family has no laptop tablet or
computer
and the power is often out anyway
i can't check their answers i didn't go
to school so instead they go to the
neighbors who do that for me
sophia's 14 year old daughter sheila
gets up at six in the morning
to do her homework
she waits eagerly for school lessons to
begin on the screen
at her neighbor's house
sometimes i just lose hope
because we don't have anything
we don't have a father
my mother is struggling for us
i need to i need to learn further
so that i can help you in the next life
i don't want him to suffer like this
and when i grow up i want to be the best
surgeon
so that i can help my mother
sheila is frightened of missing too many
lessons so she goes round to study at
her neighbors
whenever they're at home
since the beginning of the crisis the
government has been working with the
united nations children's fund unicef
to expand remote learning school
programs
what happens it's an attempt to avert
the worst
says unicef's jane ankiville
even before coffee the landing crisis
you know it was very high in
education where children are not able to
achieve the learning outcomes that they
need to achieve at a particular age
and you can imagine cluster covert then
these learning outcomes even becomes
the the achievement of the same becomes
a problem
if the power fails and the signal cuts
out then sheila simply has to miss out
on the class
which is frustrating but remote
schooling at least offers some sense of
stability during the crisis
this is also the reason why sophia
hassan invites round as many as 10 kids
a day
to use her tv in the kibra district
she wants to protect them from another
kind of threat during the crisis
it is important that you know here in
kibra there are so many
cases of violence domestic violence rape
so i'm i'm i'm trying my best to put
them together so that they they don't go
and
involve themselves there there are many
like sophia hassan
trying to help others they're the
backbone of nairobi's kibra quarter
people who won't give up no matter how
long the crisis lasts
and let's bring in the chairwoman of
save the children germany susana kruger
susanna children were labeled super
spreaders when this crisis hit
where's that put kids now
look when it comes to children the
symptoms of covet are usually mild
right and in the beginning everybody
thought well this is
not something that will affect children
very much but although
children are not particularly affected
by the virus they are
heavily impacted by the secondary and
social effects school closings for
example
lockdowns that put families under
pressure
and these changes are quite dramatic and
life-changing for children everywhere
right now
beat in the u.s either germany be it in
bangladesh south africa or europe
and what we also see everywhere it's the
most
poor and the most vulnerable that are
particularly hit
and hit the most and we will see an
increased inequality
and an increased poverty in months and
years to come
what about the extreme uh examples is
there evidence to show an increase in
violence against children and forced
child labor
yeah there there are many examples um
let me
start with protection issues the un
has described violence as a shadow
pandemic
coinciding with covet right now and
we have 243 million girls and women
that have been subjected to sexual and
physical violence and the un
says for every three months this
lockdown continues globally
and extra 15 million cases we will have
every three months and that's quite a
number
and the last two decades have actually
seen in terms of child labor 94 million
fewer children in child labor but now
that is a remarkable development right
but
now this development is under threat
because families are under pressure
when there's a lockdown they cannot go
to work that means
children and also their parents go
hungry
so children are subjected
to work and evidence about child labor
rising
as schools are closing is actually
gradually
mounting just right now we have like in
terms of numbers that you can
see it's like 152 million children
at the moment that are working as child
labourers um
72 73 million approximately in hazardous
conditions
and now what kobit does it's on the rise
for the first time
since 2000 suzanna what about
where the kids are meant to be school
what's it doing to their educations
we have an education crisis and what
that actually means um
maybe i tell you a story from from a boy
that is one of our programs in south
africa
and he's living in uh one of the
townships and
save the children works there with uh
with the families and
you know the school is closed and the
parents uh
the parents don't have internet at home
so this this boy cannot
open his email in the morning and learn
and then
the parents have only one mobile phone
and so if the father is leaving the
house for example
this mobile phone cannot used by this
boy for learning
so this is the reality on the ground for
many many kids
and they are losing out on education
tell me though what's stopping these
kids just
catching up once the crisis is over
well you see we can learn from example
from sierra leone
where save the children and other
organizations have
long time experience what it means for
girls to be out of school in sierra
leone during the epilogue crisis
there were nine months that was total
school closure
and by the end of these nine months over
10 percent
of all the girls in the country never
ever entered school again
because they were married off or it was
culturally acceptable by then
to stay at home and not to resume their
education
suzanna we're going to have to leave it
there thank you very much for being on
our show chairwoman
of save the children germany susannah
coyga thank you
so much over to our science
correspondent derek williams he's been
looking into some of the questions
you've been sending us
on the coronavirus
is there evidence that covet 19 can be
transmitted via feces
this has been a background worry all
along since kobit 19 transmission via
what's known as
the fecal oral route would have major
implications for caregivers
all over the world as well as for for
wastewater management
although it's clear that the majority of
infections occur via
respiratory droplets and aerosols it
appears that transmission of the virus
might at least
also be theoretically possible through
excrement a couple of studies have
managed to culture
live virus from patient fecal samples
like with most questions though when you
start to look into them things get more
complicated than they appear
i read an interesting new article that
helped bring home to me the complex
infection paths that pathogens can take
in the fecal oral route as they
circulate through a population
but when it came to covert 19 the
authors didn't
really make any new claims they remained
very much in in the realm of hypothesis
and and most experts continue to say
that in general
um the live virus doesn't really survive
passage
through the gut
some researchers have reported finding
the virus in sewage from samples taken
as long ago as early 2019.
can you please elaborate on that
though generally it seems to no longer
be viable
after passage through the gut um soros
cove two's
genetic material can remain intact
enough
to be detectable in feces the only
report that i've seen
claiming the virus had been found in
wastewater
collected in early 2019
was a spanish study that's still in peer
review
in it scientists from barcelona said
their tests had detected
coronavirus rna in a single sample
from march of last year but there's a
lot of skepticism that that result
is correct many experts think the sample
was likely contaminated
in the lab and and there's no way to
repeat the test
since the available sample from march
that supposedly tested positive
was apparently used up in the initial
test
studies that use sauroscope 2's rate of
mutation
to predict when it first emerged
generally trace it back to an ancestor
from late 2019 not eight or nine months
[Music]
earlier